♪ ♪
>> ♪ ♪
>> Laura: NOW TIME FOR OUR SEEN
AND UNSEEN E.G. CEMETERY.
-- SEGMENT EXPOSING THE BIG
SOCIAL STORIES.
THE DAY AFTER THE PHILADELPHIA
EAGLES WOULD HAVE CELEBRATED
THEIR SUPER BOWL WIN AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THE TEAM COACH HELD A PRESS
CONFERENCE.
"NEW YORK TIMES" AUTHOR RAYMOND
HERE TO EXPLAIN.
THIS HAS BEEN WILD.
>> THE EAGLES WON THE SUPER BOWL
OBVIOUSLY.
THE WHITE HOUSE WANTED TO HONOR
THEM.
THE WHITE HOUSE FELT THE RUG WAS
PULLED OUT FROM UNDER THEM.
80 PLAYERS SAID WE WILL ATTEND
AND AT THE LAST-MINUTE SAID 2
PLAYERS WILL ATTEND AND THE
MASCOT AND THE COACH.
THE WHITE HOUSE SAID NO WE ARE
NOT DOING THAT.
COACH PETERSON IS TRYING TO
EXPLAIN.
>> OUR ORGANIZATION.
I WAS LOOKING FORWARD TO GOING
DOWN AND BEING RECOGNIZED AD
WORLD CHAMPIONS.
IT IS WHAT IT IS.
I AM NOT DISCUSSING IT.
IT'S OVER.
>> THE OWNER OF THE TEAM WAS
RECORDED IN THAT PRIVATE NFL
OWNER'S MEETING TRASHING TRUMP.
>> Laura: I THINK THE COACH IS A
GOOD GUY.
HE WANTED TO BE THERE.
BUT HE IS SICK OF THERE.
HE JUST WANTS TO PLAY.
>> THE ORGANIZATION HAS
EXPLAINING TO DO.
WHY DID THEY PULL THIS FAST ONE?
>> Laura: THE SECRET SERVICE HAS
BETTER THINGS TO DO KNOW THAT TO
DO BACKGROUND CHECKS ON 80
PEOPLE?
>> NOW STEVEN KERR THE GOLDEN
STATE WARRIORS COACH.
>> I AM BLOWN AWAY BY THE IRONY
OF THE EAGLES TEAM DISINVITED
AND INSTEAD WE HAD MILITARY SING
ALONGS EVEN THOUGH WE DON'T KNOW
THE WORDS.
INCREDIBLE.
>> I HAVE NOT HEARD THAT MUCH
DOUBLE SPEAK SINCE JOY REID
TRIED TO EXPLAIN THOSE BLOG
ENTRIES.
IF THE WHITE HOUSE WANTS TO
HONOR YOU ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THIS IS NOT PERSONAL NOR ABOUT
TRUMP.
>> Laura: WHAT IS WRONG WITH THE
MILITARY SING ALONG?
SOMETIMES WE MISS CERTAIN WORDS,
MYSELF INCLUDED.
>> I DO THAT AT CHURCH EVERY
WEEK.
>> Laura: IT'S SNARKY STUFF.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAD THIS
CELEBRATION AND 2 GUYS KNEELED.
LOOK AT THAT ONE.
I DON'T THINK THEY ARE KNEELING.
THE WHITE SHIRT.
I THINK HE GAVE OUT FROM THE
TONNAGE HE WAS HOLDING.
>> Laura: YES.
NOW WE HAVE MELANIA TRUMP BACK.
>> OUR NATIONAL SUSPENSE HAS
ENDED.
APPEARED AT A FEMA EVENT.
26 DAYS OUT OF THE BUBBLE EYE.
-- PUBLIC EYE.
NASTY PEOPLE SAID SHE WAS
ABUSED.
HE SAID IMAGINE IF THE PRESIDENT
PUNCHED HER.
THE PRESIDENT SALUTED THE FIRST
LADY TODAY.
>> SHE WENT THROUGH A ROUGH
PATCH, BUT HE IS DOING GREAT.
WE ARE PROUD OF HER.
THE PEOPLE OF OUR COUNTRY LOVE
YOU.
THANK YOU, HONEY.
>> NOW WE HAVE KNOW MELANIA
TRUMP WAS.
SHE HAD A KIDNEY OPERATION.
IT TAKES TIME TO RECOVER.
THEY CAN ASK QUESTIONS BUT YOU
HAVE TO ACCEPT THE ANSWER.
>> Laura: PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA
TAKE MORE TIME OFF WHEN THEY GET
BOTOX.
>> I HAVE NOT HAD ANY.
MISSING PERSON.
>> Laura: SHE LOOKED FANTASTIC.
I LOVE THE OUT OF AFRICA THING.
I DON'T WANT TO APPEAR NEXT TO
HER, SHE'S SO BEAUTIFUL.
ALL RIGHT.
>> I HAVE TO SHOW YOU SOME
VIDEO.
AN FBI AGENT IN COLORADO.
DOING THE BACK FLIP AT A PARTY.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> HE FLIPS AND HIS GUN FALLS
OUT.
HE SHOOTS AN ON LOOKER AND JUST
PUTS THE GUN AWAY AND SHRUGS AND
GOES BACK TO HIS BEER.
>> Laura: DON'T CARRY A GUN AND
DO A BACK FLIP.
>> PEOPLE ARE SAYING ONLY
MILTARY AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
SHOULD HAVE GUNS.
MAYBE NOT.
SOMETIMES CIVILIANS DO BETTER.
>> Laura: A GROWN MAN DOING A
BACK FLIP.
>> AN FBI GROWN MAN.
SOMETHING SAD TO REPORT.
98-YEAR-OLD JERRY IS THE LAST OF
THE MUNCHKINS IN THE WIZARDS OF
OZ.
♪ ♪
>> ♪ WE WISH TO WELCOME YOU ♪
♪ TO MUNCHKIN LAND ♪
♪.
>> Laura: THEY WERE PAID LESS
THAN TOADO.